All you need is love and
data and computation.
Hello world,
it's Saroj and I'm going to list seven
ways to make money with machine learning.
If you're new to my channel, welcome,
hit, subscribe to get notified.
When I release new videos,
billions of dollars are being
invested into the AI ecosystem.
So unimportant question to ask is
who is currently making money in AI?
Well, at the heart of the AI ecosystem
is the data itself. Without data,
there is no AI.
It needs data to learn from and currently
the vast majority of the world's data
is owned by just a few corporations.
On top of that comes the
base layer of AI chips.
These chips are what enable AI systems
to actually perform the processing
necessary. So far, Nvidia has been
the biggest winner in this space.
Just a quick,
the lands at their stock price over the
past few years shows how influential
their GPU chips have been in the industry,
even though they were designed
for rendering graphics.
It turns out that they're perfect for
the matrix operations that a lot of
machine learning applications require,
but it's not just in IBM,
intel, Google, and now a few
Chinese companies like Cambra,
con technology are designing
their own AI chips as well.
Built on top of these chips are the
platform and infrastructure of Ai.
That is, where does the AI
processing and storage take place?
There's fierce competition amongst
companies like Amazon and Microsoft to
provide a complete cloud solution for
developers to run AI applications and the
cost of maintaining these massive global
data centers is something very few
can't afford.
On top of that are the actual
models and algorithms of Ai.
Google's tensorflow framework is still
the most popular in the field and it's
free. The reason being once
a company starts using it,
they'll likely need a lot of computing
power and who better suited to offer that
then Google, since Google cloud
is optimized for tensorflow,
once a company becomes
reliant on their software,
they will likely be a returning
customer for years. Very smart,
but that's not stopping the other giants
from releasing their own frameworks as
well. Then we have the enterprise
solutions built on all of this technology,
again, dominated by giants
like salesforce, Oracle,
which is somehow still alive and SAP.
Consumer facing solutions are being
offered by corporations that have massive
budgets and teams to
execute on innovative ideas.
And at the very top are entire
countries like China, the UK,
Germany, France, and Japan,
which are leading in terms of investment
into their respective AI ecosystems to
foster economic growth.
So where do you fit into all of this?
At the very top above countries?
Nope.
At a glance it might not seem like there's
room to make money in this space with
so many large entities
with massive budgets,
but there most definitely is.
Let's start with the first way to
make money with machine learning.
Start a startup.
There is a massive space for startups
who can provide the best vertical
solutions across industries.
Big corporations don't have time
to tackle small niche problems,
but you do.
We've seen that startups can succeed
if they have access to four components,
large datasets,
domain knowledge that gives them deep
insights into the opportunities within a
sector,
a deep pool of talent around applied
AI and capital to fuel growth.
One leading startup example is a firm
they offer loans to consumers at the point
of sale,
a very competitive space and have still
managed to build a successful company
that's raised over 700 million US dollars.
They quickly created a defensible moat
to ensure that they remained competitive.
This is called the fly wheel effect
and it applies to all AI companies.
More data begets better AI based services
and products that gets more revenue
and customers.
That gets more data and it continues.
It's the circle of data.
Startups are actually disrupting every
part of the AI value chain even at the
lowest level.
Habana for example,
is a small team developing a chip that
supposedly outruns GPU is for inference
algorithms.
Mia lets developers deploy and manage
ml models in the cloud and just a few
minutes with a much more user
friendly interface than AWS.
Clarify provides custom models and
algorithms that perform different tasks.
The are,
they're easy to use.
Api and peak is providing data analytics
as a service directly to enterprises
with so many tools freely
available on the Internet.
Anyone with the right amount of motivation
and work ethic can succeed in this
space. If I were to build an
AI startup from scratch today,
I would write down a list of problems
that I personally cared about solving.
That's the only way to stay motivated
when issues arise in your journey and they
100% will,
then I divide these problems into
whether they fit into the enterprise or
consumer markets.
The Enterprise is where the most high
value use cases for individual startups
are, so I'd probably pick
an enterprise service.
Then I create well designed landing page
with a signup form that details what my
imaginary product would
do with a price point.
After getting feedback from friends on
the pricing and features and tweaking it
a bit,
I would share it on social media
platforms to see if anybody signs up.
If people actually sign
up knowing the price.
That's extremely exciting
and motivating isn't it?
I get right to work collecting irrelevant
dataset and training a model on it.
Once I have a working model,
I take on clients one by
one slowly building the
reputation of my new brand and
use the money I earned to higher end
scale. Remember where there's a will.
There's a way nothing lasts forever.
Amazon's cloud product,
AWS,
which earns more revenue by itself
than many big corporations do,
seems unstoppable,
but a decentralized computing network
that allows anyone to use their local
machine to store and process encrypted
data could provide a lower cost option to
consumers in the near future.
The second way is contract work,
either as an individual or as a team.
I used to do contract work when I was a
college students as a way to make money
on the side and can definitely
recommended to you as well.
It's a hustle.
Clients won't come to you.
You have to go out and find them,
but before you do that,
you need to make sure you've established
a solid personal brand online that
includes a resume,
a portfolio website,
a linked in profile,
and most importantly a get hub account
with a few well documented projects that
showcase your skills
to prospective clients.
I've got a great video on this cult
resume for machine learning and how to do
freelance AI programming.
Definitely check out both of those before
browsing one of the many freelance job
board websites available on the web.
If you want to start a consulting firm,
having built an online brand is helpful
if you want access to a larger pool of
talent to join you.
Many teams these days are fully
distributed including school of Ai.
You went to find people
that you can trust,
that you enjoy working with and
that have equal or greater talent.
Then you then you can use
a team management board
like Trello to assign tasks
and split the work accordingly.
Decide what your target market is.
Then find clients in that
market by browsing social media.
Websites like linkedin and Reddit as
well as local events in your area.
For example,
consulting firms like sigmoidal focus on
working with big enterprises and medium
sized companies from just four countries.
The third way is to find a
job or internship and I've
got a great video on this
called how to find an AI internship.
Check it out.
The fourth way is to
write a technical book.
You have two options here.
Self publishing or using
an existing publisher.
I used to write blog posts
on cryptocurrency and one
of the editors at O'reilly
reached out asking if I'd be interested
in writing a book for them because they
liked one of my blog posts so much.
I ended up writing
decentralized applications
using their brand and O'Reilly
took care of marketing and distribution,
including printed copies
across many bookstores.
This is a great way to
earn a recurring revenue,
increase your brand reputation
and position yourself as
a thought leader in this
space, but be warned.
Writing a book is not easy.
I was spending eight hours every day
writing when I was staying in Tokyo for a
few months.
Write a book.
If you want to convey a way of thinking
rather than just demonstrating facts or
techniques.
What books uniquely offer the reader
as long form content is the ability to
learn how to think like the author
at a certain level of detail.
You shouldn't write a
book solely for the money,
but instead if you feel like none of
the educational content that you've seen
offers your perspective on
which technology stack works
best and envisions where
we're headed in the way that you do.
Publishers do take a royalty fee though,
and this varies per publisher if
you don't want to deal with that,
you can self publish your book
through a service like create space.
Books are a good source of passive income
there a recurring revenue stream and
you can also use the book as leverage
to later get speaking gigs like what Chi
Food Lee has been doing after publishing
his latest book, Ai Superpowers,
highly recommended by the way.
I loved it.
The fifth way is to make
educational content online. Blogs,
videos. There are a lot of
examples of this for blogs,
medium pays it's bloggers for publishing
on the platform and it's become a very
popular tool in the Ai community.
If you want to make a paid course,
you to me is probably your best bet to
get started as fast as possible without
having to build a learning
management system yourself.
But if you're willing
to play the long game,
then youtube is a great option.
You won't make money
from ad revenue at first,
but as you build an audience it will come.
You can get creative with
revenue stream here as well.
Once you've established an audience,
things like partnering with
affiliate referral programs,
Patrion and brand sponsorships.
The sixth way is to create
an automated trading bot.
I've got several videos on
machine learning for trading
in a link to them in the
description.
Creating a high frequency trading bot
focused on cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
is a popular project
idea in the Ai community.
The advantages of focusing on crypto
currencies is that you're not necessarily
starting with a handicap against the big
trading firms because the technology is
relatively new and the
APIs are really good.
People have definitely
made profitable bots,
but no one will share their source code
because that would be giving away their
secrets.
The best thing to do in this case is to
go on get hub and search for relevant
crypto trading Bot repositories until you
find some well documented examples and
learn from them.
And the last way to make money with
machine learning is to compete in machine
learning competitions.
Kaggle is a great choice.
The winners of their competitions
receive hefty cash prizes.
Knew Mariah is another good example.
Data scientists compete to see who's model
can predict asset prices the best and
earn money if they win.
Hackathons are also always a fun way to
earn prize money and there are several
listings like Katie nuggets
that help you find them.
Find a local hackathon and compete.
You could even make a living attending
and winning hackathons around the world.
Anyway, I hope you found my tips.
Useful. Wizards links to everything.
Will be in the video description. Please
subscribe for more programming videos,
and for now, I've got to make some
paper, so thanks for watching.